nous sommes aux états unis nous roulons
vert ouest chézy un village dans l'état
de new york au bord du lac champlain
nous avons rendez vous avec un homme qui
nous a mis sur une piste intéressante
john dragoon est un douanier américain à
la retraite
il possède un chalet au bord du lac près
du marina rempli d'un vote à l'eau de la
baie cette marina et les centaines de
bateaux qu'elle attire l'été l'an rage
il se sent envahi par ce qu'il dit être
un grand camping flottants c'est la baie
de monaco puis il ya aussi l'ancien
douaniers en lui qui bouillent tom
dragoon prétend que les propriétaires de
bateaux canadiens ne payent aucune taxe
sur leurs luxueuses embarcations soit
cup epec de l'efc comme un grand bout de
ces corps taxi quoi mettre au bateau de
10 millions dans late show plein et
voilà c'est hors tarifs et en politique
c'est comme le far west tout le monde
est bien gras est satisfaite si c'est
vrai on aurait donc paradis fiscal à une
heure de montréal
bienvenue au lac champlain
retour en septembre au début de notre
enquête nous roulons vert saint paul de
l'île aux noix une petite municipalité à
la frontière du québec et de l'état de
new york
nous visitons les marinas pour vérifier
s'il est vrai qu'on peut acheter un
bateau sans payer les taxes est réputé
bon vendeur de france en garde le
nouveau 38 on vend ici des produits de
luxe seilhac motorisés dépasse le
million de dollars
et il n'est pas rare que les marinades
saint-paul vendée voyez comme ceci voici
un bénéteau d'une valeur d'un demi
million $ normalement les taxes et les
vrais à 75000 dollars
et s'il a été fabriqué en europe il
faudrait ajouter des droits de douane
environ quarante cinq mille dollars
le bateau d'un demi million coûterait
donc 620 mille dollars mais pas à saint
paul de l'île aux noix
j'adore les taxes et reçoit conduire au
compteur open text saladier
je repars le monde
on vous livre le bateau donc époque taxe
parce qu'on voulait vous atelier sur la
chandelle il semble donc possible
d'acheter un bateau sans taxe si la
marina exporte le bateau aux états unis
si je le laisse sur le lac champlain
jamais jamais jamais et c'est pour
sortir car côté lac champlain qui y
jouent à 3,26 à l'eau c'est ed
beaucoup de québécois sur le lac
champlain nous sommes allés voir la
quasi-totalité du lac de 1200 kilomètres
carrés se situe aux états unis partagée
entre l'état de new york et le vermont
mais il est pas tout son canadien pour
la grande majorité du moins en apparence
des bateaux souvent très impressionnant
combien de propriétaires n'auraient
jamais payer taxes ni droits de douane à
l'achat de leurs yat ou de leur voilier
combien l'argent échappe au gouvernement
nous appelons les trois marina à saint
paul de l'île aux noix
quand elle à dire à propos de la vente
sans taxes ni droits de douane aucune
l'a voulu nous parler devant la caméra
au téléphone les trois nous assure que
la pratique est parfaitement légal tout
nous assurent qu'elles ont même la
bénédiction des autorités
est il possible que les autorités
cautionne cela nous appelons revenu
québec et l'agencé du revenu du canada
en effet il n'ya pas de taxe ni de
droits de douane à payer sur un billet
au canada c'est celui ci est exportée
dans un autre pays
nous nous présentons au poste douanier
sur la rivière richelieu
c'est le point de contrôle pour tout
bateau en provenance de saint paul de
l'île aux noix qui veut aller en ou
américaines sur le lac champlain bateau
on nous confirme que l'exportation des
bateaux respectent les règles il suffit
de remplir un formulaire
c'est la marina qui valent rien oui
parce que c'est elle qui exportent le
bateau pour vous et vous vous en prenez
possession une fois rendu aux états unis
donc à ce moment là vous avez vous le
droit de naviguer en eaux canadiennes
jamais non samba et jamais jusqu'à ce
que vous ayez payer les taxes et une foi
qui est au lac champlain les ne pouvait
pas venir naviguer vous promener dans
les eaux canadien ok les marinas disent
donc vrai dans la mesure où elle exporte
le bateau aux états unis et que le
bateau reste là il n'y a pas de taxe ni
de droits de douane à payer au canada
les scandales que tom durrr aggoun
dénonce ne serait donc pas un mais
n'est-ce pas trop beau pour être vrai
des bateaux de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de dollars syntaxe notre
enquête prend une autre tournure lorsque
nous obtenons des documents très
révélateur c'est une chaîne de courriel
daté du 14 ou la chaîne commence avec
christine gosselin une des propriétaires
de la marina gosselet à saint paul de
l'île aux noix
bonjour monsieur guy mans elle écrit
directement à un important sous ministre
à ottawa
françois guimond est responsable entre
autres de la grc et du scrs et de l'
agence des services frontaliers et
justement avec les douanes qu'elle a un
problème de source sûre les douaniers
s'apprête dès la semaine prochaine à ne
plus laisser entrer de bateaux hors
taxes au canada à moins d'obtenir des
directives écrites d'ottawa en plus de
vendre des bateaux les marinas offre un
service de réparation et d'entreposage
pour l'hiver mais comme on l'a vu les
bateaux ne doivent jamais revenir en
eaux canadiennes
sinon les taxes doivent être payés pour
contourner ce problème
les marinas du québec proposent à leurs
clients d'importer temporairement leur
bateau au canada normalement un petit
formulaire de la douane et le tour est
joué
mais l'automne dernier cette façon de
faire semblait compromise
l'ensemble des marinas de notre région
subira d'énormes pertes de revenus
c'est une catastrophe est il possible de
relancer les personnes concernées
le courriel de la propriétaire de la
marina gosselin chemine de façon
étonnante 6h24 elle l'envoie au sous
ministre
8h51 le sous-ministre le fait suivre
directement à la présidente de l' agence
des services frontaliers du canada
10h26 la présidente le fait suivre à 3
subalternes en parlant de la demande de
monsieur guy mans voilà que la demande
de la marina gosses live est devenue
celle du sous ministre lui même le jour
même la demande se répand dans
l'organisation par cinq nouveaux
messages
maintenant marquer prioritaire une
conférence téléphonique est organisée
vingt-quatre personnes sont impliquées
pour régler le problème de la marina
gosselin
un détail a aussi retenu notre attention
quand le sous-ministre fait suivre le
courriel à la présidente de l' agence
des services frontaliers
il précise qu'il se récuse mais pourquoi
se récuse t-il comment se fait-il que la
marina gosselin a un accès direct à ce
sous ministre sur son compte twitter
on voit qu'ils pratiquent la voile y
at-il un lien
retour site en dragon le douanier
américain à la retraite qui nous a mis
sur la piste des bateaux hors taxes nous
sommes venus lui montré un document
interne de l'agencé des services
frontaliers du canada que nous avons
obtenus
c'est un courriel écrit par un
fonctionnaire de lagence à une dizaine
de ses collègues vision des opérations
liées au voyage à rabat solliciter votre
aide pour assurer le suivi au sujet d'un
problème inquiétant le courriel en
anglais détaille toutes les étapes d'un
système qui permet d'éviter les taxes et
ça ne serait pas aussi légal qu'on nous
l'avait dit mais des vendeurs de bateaux
canadiens vendent des embarcations à des
canadiens aux fins d'exportation
d'abord comme on le sait déjà la marina
canadiennes exportent le bateau aux
états unis oui acheter un poisson que
les vendeurs oriente les acheteurs pour
que celui-ci prétendent exporter le
bateau afin d'éviter sciemment de payer
les taxes de vente
le bateau est aussi enregistrée auprès
de transports canada et porte un numéro
d'immatriculation canadiennes comme une
vendeuse nous l'avait dit pauli les
frais mais pas pour l'enregistrement
bateau à transports canada
nous nous enfin puis le courriel nous
révèle pot-aux-roses
la combine est complétée quand le bateau
passe aux douanes américaines les
douanes américaines qui sera en eaux
américaines pour la saison estivale
il n'a fait aucune mention
il attend son bateau de façon permanente
aux états unis
voilà donc ce qui se passe selon
l'agencé des services frontaliers
le bateau est exporté du canada mais aux
américains on raconte une toute autre
histoire
d'abord pierre adias kastens col bateau
arrive à la douane américaine
il a un numéro d'immatriculation
canadien le nom et les documents ejike
les canadiens qu'est ce qu'ils disent
aux douaniers
on s'en va à une marina aux états unis
juste pour l'été voilà la combine
on dit aux autorités canadiennes qu'on
exporte le bateau mais on ne dit jamais
aux américains qu'on a importé un bien
dans ce que si on est vraiment dans une
connivence qu'on ait ce prix pourra
l'acheter on va s'assurer d'un côté du
canada par exemple que les taxes de
vente vont pas s'appliquer parce qu'on
va l'exporter marwari ce qui est membre
des barreaux du québec et de l'état de
new york
elle enseigne la fiscalité à
l'université de sherbrooke
mais de l'autre côté de la frontière on
procédera pas l'importation donc vous
paierez pas les droits de douane le cas
échant un état de ventes à picard et ça
ça ne fonctionne pas selon la fiscaliste
la règle est simple si l'acheteur ne
paient pas de taxes au canada
il doit en payer aux états unis s'il
reste sur le lac champlain dans la
demi-heure après 90 jours le bateau
devrait trafic les par l'acheteur
l'appropriant du bateau de 0 5% de taxes
de vente pointe applicable par exemple
pour un bateau 10 ans moussa
représentant environ 50 mille dollars de
taxes de vente qui doit être remis à
l'état de new york
donc pour la fiscaliste si certains
aspects du processus pris séparément
sont légaux l'ensemble du processus
pourraient être frauduleux
si vous expliquez revenu québec où va ce
sera tant j'aime compet jeu serait
fortement étonné qu'ils arrivent à la
conclusion que tous au sénégal à ses
yeux lits marchands les acheteurs
profitent du fait que les différentes
autorités impliquées n'échange pas à
leurs informations présentant son temps
capote d'échangé de renseignements une
communication
ça va permettre uniquement aux vendeurs
canadiens ainsi qu'à l'acheteur canadien
de bonus et d'un cadre d'un produit qui
non taxables alors qu'ils devraient
l'être
selon le courriel
il y aurait 600 bateaux dont les taxes
n'ont jamais été payés sur le lac
champlain
tandja goût crois qu'il y en a beaucoup
plus c'est ridicule
il ya déjà 700 bateaux je suis si il ya
au moins 1000 bateaux de plus du côté du
vermont
tandja ghosn avait donc vu juste les
propriétaires de centaines de ses
bateaux n'ont jamais payé les taxes et
les droits de douane qu'il devrait payer
au canada ou aux états unis
certains l'ont fait surtout parce qu'ils
veulent naviguer ailleurs que sur les
eaux du paradis fiscal du lac champlain
impossible de savoir à combien s'élèvent
les pertes fiscales mais elles sont
assez importante pour que le
fonctionnaire de l'agencé des services
frontaliers écrivent ceci dans son
courriel ce problème facile et et
perpétue le non respect des lois
canadiennes et possiblement américaine
il fait perdre d'importants revenus au
canada
il faut mettre fin le plus tôt possible
à cette combine
nous appelons l' agence pour savoir si
elle mettra fin à cette combine
on refuse de nous donner une entrevue
jusqu'à présent aucune des autorités
américaines auprès desquels tom dragoon
s'est plaint nagy il doit donc
s'attendre à voir de nombreux ya hors
taxes canadienne devant chez lui
l'été prochain la propriétaire de la
marina gosselin elle a obtenu ce
qu'elles demandaient l'automne dernier à
la frontière nous avons vu les bateaux
exporté rentrer au canada à saint paul
de l'île aux noix
nous avons vu les marinas les sortir de
l'eau et entreposer les bateaux aucune
taxe n'a été réclamée
le beurre et l'argent du beurre les
acheteurs évite les taxes ce qui rend
les prix de vente des marinas plus
alléchante et ils reviennent dépenser
chez eux pour les réparations et
l'entreposage
mais au moment où on croyait notre
enquête terminée
un détail retient notre attention dans
la cour de la marina gosselet ce bateau
qui attend l'hiver sur son père un
bénéteau 2 47 pieds fait en france
un nom est écrit
f iman le sous-ministre de la sécurité
publique s'appelle françois dumont au
bureau nous consultons le style de
transports canada qui répertorie tous
les bateaux immatriculés au canada
l'elysium est bel et bien la propriété
du sous ministre et de sa femme
ils ont acquis en 2014 pour plus de 450
milles dollars les droits de douane et
les taxes sur intel voilier représente
plus de cent cinq mille dollars
oui le sédiment
oui bon je me suis dit non c'est marie
maude denis de l'émission enquête à
radio canada vous allez bien se
pourrait-il que le sous-ministre de la
sécurité publique du canada responsable
de l'agencé des services frontaliers
n'est pas payé les droits et les taxes
sur les lisières je fais exactement ce
que la mairie noble la demande par
rapport à ce qui permit à la part aux
douanes simplement
mais ce que vous importez ensuite votre
bateau aux états unis officiellement le
phare i m in aux états unis et puis moi
j'ai fait ce qui doit être fait par
rapport à la marine aux greffes l'un et
ça fait un jour de répondre par rapport
aux procédures qu'ils ont par rapport à
dwan douanes canada je trouve ça très
surprenant de réponse d'un parent d'un
sous-ministre de se référer marina pour
respecter la loi mais vous n'êtes pas
qu'on sait que certains d'entre nous
peuvent faire le pas vous demander comme
c'est étrange c'est la marina gasselin
qui gère les douanes canadiens
maintenant ce que madame gosselin
comique avec vous
enfin pour vous sensibiliser à cette
situation
je n'ai pas d'autres commentaires à
faire l' agence des services frontaliers
a refusé notre demande d'entrevue
mais elle nous a fait parvenir cette
déclaration très générales qui ne répond
pas à nos questions par exemple le
propriétaire doit payer tous les droits
et taxes applicables
l' agence des services frontaliers a
l'intention cours des prochains mois de
continuer à éduquer les propriétaires de
bateaux étrangers et les marinas
canadiennes en ce qui a trait au respect
de leurs obligations
qu'est ce que cela veut vraiment dire
qu'est ce que l' agence compte vraiment
faire
nous n'en avons aucune idée mais cela ne
l'est certainement pas entendre quelle
agence va sévir ou même inquiété sur ses
pratiques qu'elle viendra brouiller
l'eau du lac champlain est importuné la
croisière qui abusent